I'm a travel nurse I met my girl on
assignment we've been dating three years
and towards the end of it bro he's like
hey I'm not feeling this anymore I think
we need some time apart the next day she
went on a date with some guy and I
realized they were [ __ ] so this is
why you know when I say [ __ ] like she
ain't yours you know it's just your turn
I've been through it a bunch of times
women aren't sugar and spice and all
things nice and there's some women
that'll lie to you in fact most women do
lie which is why you have to judge them
by their behavior so here's the thing we
create a safe world theory in our heads
but all it takes is like Kevin from
sales to come along and pull up that one
car and then a whole [ __ ] thing comes
crumbling down and you're like what the
[ __ ] like I'm not saying don't deal with
women but be careful about the ones that
you invited to your life it's like does
she have social media was she posting
provocative pictures that was the
problem she had her IG she's putting her
leggings on when I'm like hey the
internet doesn't need to see you and
she's like I'm a diamond a diamond needs
to be put in the light to Sparkle some
[ __ ] like that get the [ __ ] out of here
I would have put my foot down and say
you know what you're actually going to
delete the Instagram if that's more
important to you I said too much man but
you're not going to do it next time no I
won't